I'm making large changes to my LIFE
GOING FORWARD.
2027 IS THE YEAR THAT WE'RE going to get
it all right, guys. We're cutting all
the toxic people out of our lives. We're
leaving all the toxic people in 2026.
Say the line, Bart. SAY THE LINE, BART.
>> [laughter]
>> SAID HE has a good reason never to be
doxed. He does this to shield his
identity.
>> [laughter]
>> Jstock didn't tell me that. Queenman
didn't tell me that. Doobie didn't tell
me that. I thought that
>> I was
myself.
>> [music]
>> So, if you guys missed it,
Counter-Points had a stream today and he
was talking to Doobie and then I think
that eventually Destiny hops on. Doobie
will make a point of, "Okay, well, when
Destiny doxes people, he's putting
people's family at risk and he's like
creating what we call a permission
structure or a a possible lens by which
people will judge him and act against
him, right? That what we principally
don't is sort of losing his moral high
ground should defend me against these
these kinds of actions, right?" Well,
they think that YOU CAN USE YOUR SEXUAL
POWER AND CLOUT AND influence and money
in order to mentally women.
Give me one example.
Anna Vor.
So, so hold on. You think Jstock,
Queenman, Esports Batman, they all hate
you for delusional or non-serious
reasons. Yes.
Uh I Okay. That's crazy.
>> Okay, dude. Because you are reaping what
you've sown. You are reaping what you've
sown and you haven't learned your lesson
and it sucks. Okay, in my current court
case drama, who what is the what what is
the stone part? What did I sow here? Was
it immoral It wasn't immoral for you to
have sex with Pixie. It was immoral for
you to take her homemade and said it to
somebody that you'd only known for 10
days. Are you going to tell me how to
run my personal life? No, but if anybody
was your friend, they would tell you an
idiot to your face, which is what I'm
doing right now. You are an idiot. You
are dumb. You ruin your own life. I see
my friend who's a
idiot
up and I've tried to be nice about it
and that's not working. So I'm going to
be mean about it. You don't know how to
manage your relationships. Anytime
anybody challenges you on anything, even
if they love you, you run away because
you're afraid of growing up. But you are
such a
that it is impossible to be your friend.
It's impossible to be your partner. It
is impossible to tell you that you're
wrong. It's impossible for you to take a
L. I might have to check out these logs.
I'm being told Destiny's crash out is
like crescendoing.
Hold on. We'll do We'll do a quick look
right now, okay? We're on the back of
last night where it's revealed that
Destiny is in fact age playing
with
a woman whose husband is a groper.
He's this person.
Almost 40. I'm worried for you. Just get
your own side. You're just not very
grown up. What do you want me to say?
That's a personal problem. Don't take it
out on me, Connor.
Grow up. You're 40. Grow up. Connor, you
are on the internet talking about You
are age playing with a groper's wife.
Jesus.
Well, that's pretty you know.
And
the thing is is
Here's the thing. Would that be enough
to make Connor crash out? I don't know.
Maybe. It might be.
But there was another log here that I
responded to earlier today on Twitter,
okay? When you get these logs today from
Destiny, these other two people are not
public people at all. But I'm sure their
friends and people they know are
watching. So for me to say anything at
all about this particular situation will
take all of their personal business up
and throw it into the public light. Why
the
would anyone ever subject someone to
that? Both of the parts of that couple
were literally begging Connor to stop
leaking / publicizing anything.
From experience, anytime Destiny invokes
somebody else's privacy
in any way, whenever he goes, "Oh, you
need to respect this person's privacy.
NO, NO, YOU'RE GOING TO YOU'RE GOING TO
INVADE THEIR PRIVACY. NO, I'M I'M
WORRIED FOR THEIR SAFETY." When Destiny
leads with like empathy for another
person, that is always automatically a
shield for some like egregious behavior
he's engaged in.
He's never once been concerned about
people's privacy. Just look at what he's
getting sued for.
Like literally take 2 seconds, give your
head a shake, and think about what the
this idiot is getting sued for, right?
It's so
obvious. It's so obvious. Honor has been
bending if not breaking his own
principles for the sake of Destiny's
online reputation. For Destiny to to
talk to him and start asking for more is
what broke Honor off. When Destiny said
he was entitled, boom, glass shattered.
Yeah, when Destiny said you people are
so entitled, absolutely.
Honor leaks intimate DMs.
And you know what?
>> Wait, what?
>> I'll say this, too.
BPD girl, her message to me is, "Oh my
god, please stop. He's never going to
talk to me again."
>> [laughter]
>> I By the way, I Connor is still There's
like levels to deprogramming.
And I know Listen,
I know people I'm like think I'm
motivated in doing this. I'm really not,
but people think it's like me just
having motivated reasoning and wanting
to do this or something. It's not. But
that is a part of the framing that
allows this kind of a like abuse to take
to continue over time, right? I'm just
saying.
Anyway, that's what's going on. Steven
casually engages with mentally ill
women. Jeez.
Dark. Little dark.
Feels kind of dark.
>> You're pretty crazy.
We got to keep going, man. There's too
much. There's too much. There's too
much.
So annoying. He is not representing
anything of this person correctly, but
he is dragging so many people's business
out into the public eye, and it is
impossible to talk about it without just
outing so many people's business.
I hope after Connor finally implodes, he
at least haunts the right person.
I wonder who the right person is. I feel
like I'm in his head just from this just
from this mistype right here.
I'm like I'm literally in his head from
this mistype. I almost dropped the
divorce thing right there.
Well, W, oh, he's just reacting to um
the Hutch stream. By the way, both the
Striper and his wife were begging Connor
to [__] off last night and to stop
dragging their business out in the open.
I don't need recommendations from you
for how to run my life. Number one.
Number two.
>> Yes, you do, you dumb because you keep
burning your own life. Number [snorts]
two, I'm not the one who needs
>> a
social worker. Holy [__] you're so ass
pain over your obsession with my life.
No, I'm not, you Okay, fine. Just shut
up. Shut up. I'll just say it. I'll just
say it.
After you leaked homemade
After the entire internet hate Oh, wait,
this is the point I wanted right here,
okay, to keep reading the logs. You
started with another woman on Discord.
Are you And you [__] did age play
with Wait. I
am a little confused.
Dude, Hutch
Hutch consistently is like the worst
reactor that exists. Like, dude,
this is like such awful content, man.
And he had 4,000 viewers or something
today.
He pauses perfectly to cut off the point
to go, "Ah,
I'm like a little confused. I
like, what's
going on here? Like,
wow.
Wow, what's going on, man?
Wow. How did this come up again? If it's
like the conversation about the snarky
people, why did this come up again?
Because when Destiny tries to portray
himself as the victim, he has to lie
completely. Hutch, welcome to your life.
Hutch, this is the ghost of your
Christmas future right here, okay?
You're going to defend some of this
conduct. You're going to realize that
the people who are upset, this is the
infinite Destiny cycle, okay? It's why
he can't maintain any relationships.
You're going to realize that when you
swept for this in about a year, maybe a
year and a half, you'll realize that
sweeping for this was a huge mistake and
you'll feel like a complete [__]
Okay?
And
and
you'll be in Connor's position cuz
Destiny will have like changed his story
on all of this stuff. It'll all be way
different to meet whatever new crazy
[__] he's done.
And Connor understands that basically
his criticisms from before are being
laid out as insane. Like he's totally
switched his positions from before.
Connor is saying the same thing he was 1
year ago. But now because because of how
Destiny's approaching the situation,
now even though Connor's saying the
exact same thing he was a year ago, he's
suddenly a liar. He's like a liar who
wants to destroy Destiny's life and is
obsessed with Destiny's [__]
Very cool.
>> and she was MARRIED TO SOMEONE ELSE. AND
SHE WAS MARRIED TO A GROPER.
SHE was married to a groper. Do you
think it is
prudent to
text message somebody who's married to a
groper?
I Connor, aren't you divorced? Do I need
to pass
>> [gasps]
>> Oh my god. through every single person
that messages me with a nude or wants to
send Is that what I need to do Do I need
to get permission from you from now on?
Are you going to tell me how to run my
personal life? No, but if anybody was
your friend, they would call you an
idiot to your face, which is what I'm
doing right now. You are an idiot.
You are dumb.
You ruin your own life.
Okay. All right.
Does any What is happening?
It's
I I shouldn't laugh because it's a
deliberate strategy, right?
Hutch I don't know how
How deliberate [clears throat] is it
from Hutch? It's like a deliberate
strategy to go like, "This is crazy and
like should be private. You shouldn't
talk about any of this in in public at
all." But Destiny constantly makes this
stuff public. Constantly makes this
stuff public, okay?
And he is not somebody who could be held
privately accountable. If he was, I'm
sure he would have changed before.
Right? This how he demonstrates how
normal he is. I know that's what he's
trying to do, but it's like it's an
actual real like problem that Hutch
wants to pull this up and he he's
playing into a system he doesn't
understand, which is
I mean, probably his entire life,
really. So,
hard to get like too angry at him. I
just I I just get annoyed cuz the
content is dumb. Like he just pauses and
goes, "This is so online. I don't even
know what the dude you watch this 8
hours a day."
That's what we're doing here.
>> being sued for leaking homemade
Should you start text messaging a woman
who's married to a political opposition
that hates your
guts?
Connor, at this point
>> sane or normal behavior?
>> the world hates my guts, Connor, but
what I do with my
>> Wait, okay, so the whole world hates
YOUR GUTS. HOW DO YOU KNOW IT'S DOOBIE
SWATTING YOU?
>> do Connor, what I do I've never said
that Doobie himself swatted me. Birdman,
thank you. What's How do you know it's a
snarker?
Because these guys literally have the
slogan at the beginning of their Wait,
wait, but but but but the Hutch
Uh Doobie didn't
It's so awesome that it's so awesome
that this has come out now that there's
like a reason like we could basically
point to. It was always like this.
But basically it's like Destiny was sort
of tying the group to KF or something.
And if he has if he has like a website
zero element here where he knows that
there are other people who are trying to
do this stuff to him,
and he's still blaming this like he he
was already doing it with KF, okay?
But if he's doing it to an extra degree
again, he's just full-on Keppels lolcow
spiraling.
That's awesome. You love to see it. Like
there's I just wasn't prepared for it to
go to that extent, okay? I was I didn't
think that's what the way it was, but
that do be how it is, Mr. Stansel. It do
be like that. Mr. Stansel.
>> Speak up in chat, and I didn't realize I
could I clicked on his name on the super
chat and
it didn't give me the option to hide
user from channel. It just let me I
don't know what I'm talking about. I
don't want your money, Doobie.
husband
But the husband Buttermilk with the tier
one membership, thank you. Was in a
telegram where groupers were plotting
your murder. If they were plotting your
murder,
then don't you think they might swat
you?
I don't know, they might, but I've
gotten swatted so full You're so You are
so
full of
You are so full of [__] You want You
want to blame
exclusively
Kweiman, Jay Stalk, all of these people
for what What does Kweiman
and Jay Stalk
Kweiman
What is Oh, the timestamp. Yeah, it's
coming up. 2 minutes. What is What is
What is What is What is What is What is
What is
Dude, it's so I I'm sorry, it's
like he
I have no patience for people who are
like intentionally ignorant or or
willfully ignorant. I have no patience
for it. Like you've talked about this
guy enough. Learn how to say his name.
That's all you got to do. Just learn how
to say the name. It's not a Stop. And
yet you always poke the bear. You always
crazy
You It's EVERYBODY ELSE'S FAULT.
EVERYBODY else's fault. It's never
Destiny's fault. It's never s-
I just What does What does Kweiman have
to do with um like
Destiny's
life? Well, you see, Hutch, it started
one day in an Euler call.
We loaded up some videos.
Sorry, that's a that's a joke that's
hinting at like an old thing Destiny
used to accuse us of that was obviously
like stupid. That's a joke. That's a
joke. That's a joke. That's a joke. What
What is the connection there?
Um am I missing lore?
Very I'm very confused. Um Jen with
the year, thank you so much. Appreciate
that.
Steven Salt
He manages to perfectly pause in these
situations
to prevent or sorry, to prevent
understanding. Like he pauses explicitly
in a way that stop his ability to
understand the situation. Like when
Connor first mentions the age play
thing,
Hutch is like pausing as it's being said
and he doesn't get it.
He doesn't understand, doesn't hear it
all. Yeah, we can't do a moral inventory
about
>> Caramel Colbert with $20, you deserve a
donno for being fair and balanced. What
the You're doing every single Who does
Hutch talk to from the other side of
this issue at all?
Fair and balanced. Fair and balanced.
>> You don't have to talk to me if you
don't want to, but you should probably
talk to somebody who knows any of this
stuff, right?
Like Hutch just doesn't care. Lots of
people can lay this out. Hutch just does
not give a
Connor. Like there is a context where
if I was like Destiny's friend, like if
we were close like that. And again, this
comes from like recovery, the Oh, I
think Hutch Hutch does some stuff about
tying this into recovery. It's like he's
um
This is he's he's basically become like
a another Notsocreative. Notsocreative
basically put Destiny in this box of
like traumatized person who could do no
wrong and he was good they were going to
be infinitely charitable to.
What Hutch I I defended Hutch when he
said this originally. Like, okay, Hutch
didn't really know what was going on. He
wasn't going to look into it. He wasn't
going to take a side. He just said,
"Hey, I know that he's like hurt this
person and I'm not going to cut him off
forever, but it seems like a toxic
situation and I do believe in
redemption, so I'm not going to say I
would cut him off forever, right?"
And then he just started talking about
how everything had changed
without explaining what had changed
ever. Right? He doesn't have a good idea
of what has changed. He's just sort of
rationalized the things that are
convenient for him. The things that
basically give him money, clout,
influence, viewers, all of this stuff,
right? He's rationalized moving in that
direction.
Oh well, things really changed. Okay,
what changed? What has changed?
What do you think's changed, Hutch?
It pisses me off because the idea that
you're even even the idea that
because the signal you can't say the
signal, right? Like I actually know how
to say his name. You couldn't say it.
Can't say I actually know. It's when you
feign that ignorance to make the signal,
it annoys me. It's like honestly, even
if you
I don't even care about doing that. If
you want to signal somebody's opinion is
not valuable, do that. But the idea that
you're like stupid to do it annoys me.
The recovery relationships that you make
when when you start going to like NA
meetings and working a program,
the culture is to use like very blunt
language. Oh, yeah, this is the problem
is you've got an addict who's never able
to hit. Actually, here is the analogy
that Hutch needs.
You have an addict who is not even close
to hitting bottom,
and you've got a bunch of people like
you Hutch are participating in this
right now, who are holding him up,
right? This person basically cannot get
better. They're very harmful in the
current state they're in. They cannot
get better without hitting rock bottom,
and you are one of the people holding
them up.
Right? You're the one of the people
who's going to sacrifice your
reputation, sacrifice your happiness
ultimately to hold them up, and
realistically,
I
I you can't see it, but it's happening.
Right? He has to admit he has a problem.
Yeah, exactly.
The admission of the problem is required
to and that's the thing that annoys me
about Hutch actually, because
he said like as long as this guy's on
the path to redemption, I could forgive
him. And I just want to know what
indication has there ever been that
Desi's on the path to redemption, that
he is sorry for what he's done, that
he's attempting to do any sort of
penance or
like payback any of the harm he's done
in the world, right? To
not recompense, but to like
give any restitution back to the people
he's hurt.
There's there's just nothing. He's not
trying to make amends.
And I do think that's an important part
of a program, right? Is to let people
know you you did hurt them. Their their
feelings like towards you were valid.
You had a problem. But Destiny can't do
that. He's incapable.
Why I said penance first. There's a word
I'm looking for, but um
Anyway, like that is critical to being
forgiven and starting to get better. And
Destiny hasn't hit that bottoming out
point where he's going to apologize to
people who he's harmed and try to get
better.
Right?
Yes, he doubles down and goes on the
attack. Exactly.
And like I could frame this in Hutch's
way. I don't like him because he's
actively harmful to people, right?
But I can frame it in that way for
Hutch. I I don't think he would even try
to understand that, right?
Not even a little bit. He would never
try to understand that. I think Connor
and Destiny were like legit friends
outside of streaming, so I assume they
talked about this stuff. I'm not really
sure. And and like superficially, yes.
Like it is appropriate sometimes to tell
your friends, just like I said a minute
ago. It is sometimes appropriate to say
like, "Hey,
um
there's one thing that all of these
things have in common and it's that it
involves you. And so you [clears throat]
probably need to look at yourself. Like
that's a perfectly reasonable comment.
I another thing going on here is that
Destiny's actually just like a
pathological liar.
And so like if you try to confront him
on something,
you'd need like all of the people
present who are involved in the
situation. Because otherwise, he's going
to have a he has a very good idea of how
to compartmentalize information.
Nobody's told specific people but
specific things and he will he will just
lie.
And so that is probably his biggest, you
know, where people see the most into how
he operates is when he like things are
litigated publicly because he can't go
backwards, right? Hutch doesn't know
enough. He shouldn't be covering this.
Otherwise, it's just going to be him
sweeping. Well, he is going to sweep.
The real problem here would be Hutch not
willing to speak to somebody who has the
facts, right? Like Hutch probably should
be willing to talk to like a Doobie.
Hutch probably should be willing. But
here's the thing, anybody who learns the
facts probably doesn't have positive
feelings towards Destiny and probably
gets labeled a snarker pretty quickly.
Right?
And so for Hutch, I I just don't know
where he's ever going to get the
information he would need to make a good
decision here. Conversation to have with
a friend.
I've had those kinds of conversations
with friends. People have come to me
with those kinds of observations about
me. Those are the kind of friendships
that you want.
Like you you want friendships with
people that are going to hold you
accountable and not cosign bad behavior.
The problem with having this
conversation on a live stream is once
you add this element of an audience
then the conversation takes on a whole
new meaning. Because, and I don't
pretend to know how Connor's mind works,
but it's possible that in Connor's mind
he is like fighting for his internet
life, you know? Like he has this
long established friendship with
Destiny. There's there's there's a
ongoing, you could say like work
relationship or work acquaintanceship.
Um
as far as I understand, a lot of like
audience overlap. And so
there could be these other factors that
kind of pervert the conversation and
then and then it becomes about something
other than what you're talking about. I
don't know. Does that make sense? I'm
trying to explain myself here.
Like I don't know if they're having a
conversation really about the thing
that's being discussed.
It just It doesn't seem like it's about
that in this moment. It seems like it's
about something else, you know? Cuz you
have like this audience that are going
to be like they're they're going to be
tribalistic with with online
communities. And so you have a lot of
people that are like fiercely loyal to
Destiny that are part of his community.
And now he's like the villain, the bad
guy in that in that space. And
he's probably like experiencing the
consequences of that. I'm sure his
mentions look crazy right now. And maybe
that makes him want to dig in more. And
maybe you know, so there's like all
these other complicating factors. It's
just
Basically like all of the things that
they're presenting as a totally evil
[__] that I've I've done, like which is
actually pretty much just the reporting
thing, they're all threatening to do to
Connor now in a way that I never did,
not even in the worst of times. They're
like saying they're going to call
Connor's sponsors. It's just
Dude, it's crazy. It's crazy how hard
they're going.
>> So dysfunctional. This is not how
Fake neutrality from Hutch is so cringe,
bro.
Yeah. I do wonder just how much of it is
intentional and understood. Do you know
what I mean? Like just how much of
Hutch's performance here is him
intentionally and and understandably
trying to
get that audience on his side. And let
me tell you when you when you 4x your
audience size cuz you're giving a
certain opinion, it has a an effect and
a feeling on you that is difficult to
resist.
Like I think you have to be a very
strong person to resist that at all.
And Hutch is going to be experiencing
that a lot. I think he had 4,000
concurrent viewers earlier today when
he's covering this.
Like that is going to be really really
hard to resist. My sponsors, do they
just mean Midas? Yeah, I think they do.
How
these kind of conversations
They named somebody who runs the Valor
media thing. Um
when done correctly and done with like
good intentions. If your intention truly
is
you care about your friend and I I I I I
I I I I I I I
and you you want them to make better
decisions, then like that that um
that's one thing. But if your intention
is to like defend yourself against like
an internet community and and I don't
know, it's just like it it makes these
kinds of discussions like literally
impossible in this kind of a setting.
Granddad's Lounge with 5 lbs. Problem is
D has had these conversations over 3
years and made the requested changes to
his life. That's why even the Pixie is
3+ years old. Thoughts with D with $10.
The thing that I don't get is let's say
Connor's right and Destiny did bring
this on himself. How does it justify
folks like Hutch and Wick getting
targeted? Well, I I I I I think that's
the point that that Destiny is like
explicitly making, right? Um Adrian with
with $5. I believe Connor has some
mental stuff going on and is using
Destiny as a way to lash out. He needs
to find a therapist. Styrofoam. Well,
probably everybody in this Discord call.
Dude, you have no idea how often that's
Destiny's response to people just
expecting him to be a decent person.
You're like you're like totally mentally
unstable. You're like totally mentally
unwell. You're like really really You
need to get You need to get help. I
don't know what's happening with you
right now, Connor. Maybe you need to
take a week off. Maybe the divorce is
just a bit too much, man. Dude, it's so
crazy listening to this happen, man.
That you were
an unstable woman who is still
threatening
at this moment, and who was married to
your political opposition who wants to
you. I just want to ask you one fair
question. Who who gave you this idea
that this person is like anything
relevant to any of the past year Who are
they talking about, guys? Are they
talking about Lauren Southern?
Who's this person that was married to a
groper? Who is this person? Does anyone
even know who the they're talking about?
No, different person? Okay.
I don't know. I don't know. Guys, I
can't follow anything. I just I What is
happening, guys?
Guys, what is happening? I I'm lost.
What is happening? What?
What?
and a half of real life harassment
towards other people I know, of
harassment towards anybody who was on
social media, of interviewing my court
cases, of reaching out to witnesses who
he did
mentally unstable woman that you are Her
name is it First of all, I'm not talking
about this person right now, okay?
Number one. Number two, she said that
I'm not talking to this person right
now.
>> [laughter]
>> It's so funny watching it happen in real
time. The little corrections.
>> woman that you are Her name is it First
of all, I'm not talking about this
person right now, okay? Number one.
Number two, Does Hutch catch any of
this? It's so funny, man.
Like, what does he mean by right now?
Like, right this second, in the past
day, or Oh, so much of this behavior is
aloof maxing, if you pay attention.
Well, hold on. Here's the thing, Evil
Johnny Bravo. The issue for Hutch is
that he is this stupid when it comes to
like when it comes to covering politics
and stuff, too. Like, he is just this
dumb basically all the time. So, while
it could be aloof maxing, while he could
really be trying to like just sweep this
up, he is also quite dumb in regular
situations, like quite incapable of
processing information.
So, like it I guess it could go either
way. Depends on how much he watched
before he decided to cover this, right?
But, anyway, they're talking about the
Britt person that's been brought up.
>> said Is that who she is? Sorry, what? Is
that is she is her name online? She's
the one in in JustPearly's Discord
server that reached out to the victim of
But if you think you get [__] Wait,
wait, wait, hold on. If You're you're
you're saying Hold on, hold on, hold on.
You're saying I shouldn't care about
your life when you're doing something so
reckless and stupid it runs the risk of
you getting murdered? I as your friend
shouldn't have criticism of you? The
amount of The amount of pivot sweep that
you've done, none of this has anything
to do with my court case. You are
desperately running from it because you
know that you can't defend it.
>> it did, you
I said that you are s-
and you're dangerous to yourself. Dude,
I'm Do you understand? So, there's this
thing Destiny does that he only ever
uses other people's boundaries, I find,
when he's done something wrong. Like if
he doesn't want to go to a to a
conversation or a situation,
he only uses boundaries of other people.
He He doesn't think about boundaries of
other people. He only does it when he's
like trying to protect from something.
Which is like, man, he's
And now Connor's saying like, I didn't
say that has anything to do with this. I
called you
Connor's really mad about him this
woman. I'm thinking Connor is like quite
disgusted by whatever conversations he's
had with that couple.
You know what I mean? Like there's
something more to this situation. All
right, that's good. That is basically
nothing to do with any of the problems
that I've been experiencing for the past
2 years, but unless I get
>> You don't think that you're in a court
case right now because you're
in a danger to yourself?
Oh, also, yeah, I guess it does flow
quite nicely into the fact that he
started trading homemade that he didn't
have consent to trade with a woman he'd
known for 10 days that wasn't a woman
that was pretending to be an 18-year-old
girl who was actually a 26-year-old man
who was in fact using the pictures of a
17-year-old girl. Who was the I was for
recording videos with Pixie. I shouldn't
have done that.
6 years ago.
>> No. Oh, well, maybe, but
>> Laura and I should have
>> you're almost there. You're
Dude.
You're saying I just like can't have s-
then Connor? Are you Connor? You're just
basically saying that s- is wrong. Okay,
Connor, that's your criticism. You're
blowing up our friendship because you
think s- is bad. Is that what it is
Connor? Just the performative
the performative like oh I couldn't
possibly understand what you're actually
mad about Connor. I couldn't possibly
understand what you're actually mad
about Connor. What what are you actually
mad about? I have no idea what you're
actually mad about Connor.
>> Almost at the point that's actually a
good point.
Yeah, please please articulate yourself
and how it resulted in a court case.
Please do.
is you just not liking people having
casual OR DOING
>> [laughter]
>> NO WAY. WAIT, I DIDN'T KNOW HE ACTUALLY
SAID IT. I DIDN'T KNOW HE ACTUALLY SAID
IT.
DUDE, NO SHOT. No
shot. He literally just said it out loud
that that is the only problem. That must
be the problem you have Connor. You just
don't like casual
No, that's are you being sued for casual
sex?
No, no, no, no. Me, because I'm a sane
adult, I don't like that my idiot
millionaire friend who is wildly
intelligent, wildly successful in so
many domains of his thought [__]
that it was smart to send homemade
to random people on the
internet.
That's why I'm calling you
Jay didn't tell me that, Weeman didn't
tell me that, Doobie didn't tell me
that. I thought that you were
myself and I called you
for two
years.
No comment from Hutch by the way. No
comments from Hutch. This is This is
Hutch as he listens to this, okay? sane
adult I don't like that my idiot
millionaire friend who is wildly
intelligent, wildly successful in so
many domains of his life, thought that
it was smart to send homemade
to Like the face is almost doesn't even
make sense for what's being said, right?
Like that He's actually bad at capturing
a response to a situation with his face.
Like he's facially too. Like he he's not
just slow and unable to retain
information.
He's also like bad at making the face
that is appropriate for the situation.
Genuinely, he looked like he just he
looks like he just stepped outside and
the sun's in his eyes. Well, random
people on the [__] internet.
That's why I'm calling you
J Scott didn't tell me that. Leeman
didn't tell me that. Doobie didn't tell
me that. I thought that you were
myself. Called you
for two [__] years. That makes sense.
>> And you're still
If a Justical fan showed up at my home
and murdered me because they were so
upset over the court case, would that be
my fault?
Sorry, if who showed up and murdered
you?
>> A Justical fan showed up at my home and
murdered me because they were so upset
about my behavior. Would
You think fans of mine are like really
concerned about this stuff? I mean, I'm
sure they are, but do you think that's
like their primary drive at this point
or they watched you be a total psycho
who's like threatened people's safety in
this community like all around this
place?
Like which one which one do you think it
is? Do you think it's all the threats?
I'd say people in my community who are
actually under threat by you probably
they're like pretty upset, no?
At you like directly for your behavior.
It's probably you trying to dox a bunch
people, right? Right? Just be real for 2
seconds. That'd be my fault. How about
we change it to the graper? Can can you
ask
>> answer that question? You No no no I
I'll answer your question.
Why the [__] do they think you guys are
the really angry ones? There are other
communities way more likely to do that.
Like I think Destiny understands this
that he's fought with a bunch of online
communities that would hate him and have
long-term antipathy towards him.
And by the way, like I don't want
to be real like
it's wrong to do
but even if I didn't have a principle
against it it would just be stupid to
do. Like I want to do this long-term on
the internet. I don't want to do I don't
want to [__] around with that stuff,
right? Like I I I'm principally against
it, but even if I wasn't even if I
thought it was like a reasonable tactic
that's on the table because of the
downside like socially or
professionally, I wouldn't want to do
it.
You know what I mean? Uh in terms of
him, I I also have a principle and I I
wouldn't want to do any of the adjacent
stuff either. The the whole like
collateral damage thing is [__] up.
Yeah, it's just not good. Well, it's not
good for business because he's like
blaming me for it and he started trying
to do this the same [__] back to people
in my community and I'm just like,
"Dude, it's
Like I don't Hey, I just You could just
respond to the arguments on stream, man.
What the hell?
What is my next timestamp? My next
timestamp is
right here.
This is where we move forward in the
conversation, okay? Uh Shen with $2, do
you think Connor has no valid critique?
Um
Well,
>> [screaming]
>> Dude.
Dude, what?
Dude. [laughter]
Do I have this sped up, too? Hold on,
there's no way I don't No, I have it on
1x, okay. It's hard for me to give an
opinion, again, because
Like no, I mean, sure, yes. I think I've
said that
at many, many points in this stream.
It's not that there's It's not He's
going to say something, but it's like,
"It's not that he doesn't have a valid
critique. It's that that is all private
and it should be pri- private only." And
like, you should never Dude, what about
him
violating people's consent with that
with the sharp
recording
audio encounters without people's
consent? What about that stuff? Is
it that should not be talked about
publicly?
He's literally getting sued for it for
one thing because of his sloppiness,
because he was somebody that he knew for
10 days and sending other people's to
them. That stuff in the public.
That's his fault.
It's not only his fault, but it is his
fault. Like, he is the person who was
the custodian of that and sent it to
other people. He is to blame. Not that
it's never appropriate to tell a friend
when you think that they're being
self-destructive or impulsive or
making bad decisions. Like
of course there are there are contexts
where not only is that appropriate, but
that that would be like the sign of a
good friend.
Of course.
Okay.
>> it's it's the tying
the critique of Destiny's like
um
social life
or romantic life or life. And then tying
it into the conversation about like
snarkers and then that's just gone. Like
at some point in the discussion
we're not even we're not even talking
about snarkers anymore. It's just Connor
putting Destiny on trial for his sins.
And
Yeah, so Hutch just doesn't have the
context here, right? The context is that
Counter-Points has defended Desti for a
very long time and defended him having a
chance to change, right? And Desti's
shown no proclivity for change. Desti
has basically spit in Counter-Points'
face
by refusing to even entertain change.
Right?
And also like a lot of the things that
Desti the narratives Desti's are running
with now are so Trumpian and so far away
from the truth that Connor probably
feels like
guilty or weird in participating in
them, right? Like he's just making
things up and
telling his audience it's the way it is
with almost no proof at all. It's just
very Trumpian. Connor, in terms of like
who's dangerous to internet politics
right now, I would say Desti's far
outstripping Hasan [__] If Desti were
to get, you know, a couple of these
snarker people
deplatformed or like just made them run
scared through doxing threats and [__]
If he was able to do this enough and
stabilize his platform and get back to
politics, why would you want a total
psychopath like that in your political
movement? It doesn't make any sense.
This is just not
an appropriate venue for that kind of
conversation.
You would never have this kind of
conversation like this on a live stream.
There's no way any anybody could could
justify this kind of a conversation on
on a stream like this. It's just like
we're not even
Why? We're not even talking about
sneakers anymore. We're just It's just
like Connor prosecuting this case
against Destiny and
hard to make sense of it. I don't really
understand where this is coming from,
but I don't really know Connor that
well. I don't really know Destiny that
well. I don't really know their
friendship that well. I don't know. I
don't know how much they talk behind the
scenes. I genuinely have no idea.
Um Boris with $10 D gets the girl Connor
asks out and then lets her go. It must
have made Connor feel small and now he
wants to feel vindicated that he can
think it's D's. I'm not going to
speculate on the particulars.
I genuinely
have no idea what is making Connor tick
in this moment. Uh the trip with $5
saying you want Destiny to slow down
with his sec
with his what? With his sec is that what
you mean? Uh sure, saying you're running
your own life which removes agency from
bad actors is not valid.
Uh he literally is the He is the person
who's ruining his own life. That is I'm
sorry. He just is. Nothing I can do can
hurt Destiny unless I'm saying the
truth.
Right? I cannot just make things up
about Destiny. And that's why they're
getting blown up. That's why That's why
Dessy's losing it so badly because when
you just say like blatant lies like
obvious overt lies all the time like him
and Dan are doing right now in this
situation, nobody believes you. You You
destroy your credibility. And that's
what Destiny had for a long time, right?
That's why he built the audience he did
that was so helpful, that was so useful,
that would do so much for him.
He's got a different audience now, but I
don't think it's a very good one. I
don't think it's a very strong one. I
Like some people are back, but I think
they're back cuz they have empathy for
him as a friend. I don't think they're
the kind of people who would engage in
like the [__] that's How do I put it? I
don't think these are the kinds of
people that would engage in the [__]
he's doing in terms of like going after
people personally. They might be in the
community, they might want to show
solidarity. Like I'm assuming that's how
Mouton came back was basically like
somebody reached out to him was like,
"Hey, this guy's like losing it. This
guy's having a really rough time."
You know what I'm saying? Anyway.
Anyway.
I But the the community was there
because they liked that he was driving
towards the truth. That's where I was
going with that, right? That he used to
be known for driving towards the truth,
the guy who's like based in fact.
And they've gotten so far away from
that.
It's like very very very bizarre. Oh,
weird.
>> Um Connor Connor originally was bringing
all this up as some kind of a
justification, not maybe not a
justification, but like
pretense or explanation for like the
snarker behavior. And
he just like lost me right away with
that. That's not a reason to like
somebody having
even even even if the behavior is bad
uh
uh questionable
just making questionable decisions as it
pertains to their love life
is not a justification to
the kind of obsession that you can see
in the logs. That's kind of crazy. Dude,
the logs dude, he
Again, he's talking about the obsession.
The sad thing is truly Destiny was not
discussed anywhere near as much as
people might think from what these guys
talk about, right? Like I do think Hutch
was talked about more
in that server. Like I
People basically are like kind of
grossed out by Destiny. Like they don't
want to watch him in a lot of different
contexts. So, Hutch was talked about way
more cuz Hutch was somebody who like
wasn't disgusting.
And he would say really dumb things and
it was like funny to watch him, okay?
It's like one of those people like I
assume if you have a really really dumb
enemy, you like laugh at them a lot and
you you bring them up all the time,
right? That's sort of what it was with
Hutch was he just would say really
stupid [__] all the time. And so we
would watch him and laugh.
But I I don't think Destiny came up
anywhere near as much as Hutch. Or I
don't think they came up the same
amount.
Maybe Destiny came up nearly as much,
but anyway, we keep going.
>> suggest. The implication is like he
brought it on himself, but these these
people are are relentless, obsessed, and
motivated
very explicitly motivated
to destroy not only Destiny's life, but
anybody who comes within like three
degrees of separation from Destiny.
It's
completely unacceptable behavior. That's
wildly disproportionate to
whatever controversies Destiny is
involved in from time to time. Michael
with $5 last night's argument was as
serene Branson once said, very, very
heavy birdtation. I don't know what that
means.
Hmm, I don't know how much more we've
got of the hot stuff. I'm going to read
a few more logs here, and then we can
keep going. I think the next time step I
have is when Wick calls in. Okay?
Dear Greek, is he age playing with me
when he tells me to grow up?
Oh my god.
Why the [__] would he bring this up? So
cringe. Why would he get this on
himself? So cringe. Bro, this is
literally only funny to me because of
how clueless Connor was here. But in
retrospect, THIS IS ACTUALLY SO INSANELY
GROSS THAT HE THOUGHT he was ambushing
me here. I can't believe this is my
life. NBA player smiling in the rain
meme. I don't know what that meme is.
Valrein, I cannot talk about this
because it comes off as insanely
self-grandiosing. Aggrandizing, I think
is what he means. Insanely
self-grandiosing, but a huge
psychological driver to a lot of my
haters is that I have way more than I
ever deserved to have. And it's hard for
them to reconcile it. I mean, that might
be true. I just don't really care.
That he has way more than he deserves. I
just don't super care.
You know what I mean?
Like
Sir, you could say that about a lot of
people. I'm sure the In terms of what
people deserve in this world, you don't
get what you deserve. You know what I
mean? You don't get what you've earned.
You Like it's the world's not fair.
I don't let that That doesn't [__] with
me. I don't know about other people.
Example, I'm short, not super built or
anything. There's no world where I
should be banging hot chicks. I'm very
aggressive and mean sometimes, but don't
ride it with any political group.
There's no way I I should have an
audience, but I do. I'm not particularly
well educated. I don't come from money
or any amazing genetics talk or
anything. So, I shouldn't do as well as
I do for debates. For all these points,
people have to find it obsess over the
specific copes. Otherwise, they can't
handle their own lives are. Example,
well, girls just want him for his money
or because he abuses or manipulates
them. Or well, he only has an audience
because he brainwashes the cult. Or
well, he's not a good debater or smart.
He just tact uses tactics on people.
You'd be sixes if you didn't have money
and clout. That's just facts.
May maybe not sixes, man.
To be honest with you. I'm just saying
it's the money and clout thing 100%.
Um well, he only has an audience because
he brainwashes the cults. No, you used
to be funny.
You're like funny and edgy back in the
day. That's why you have an audience.
You've totally lost your sense of humor.
You got no humor to you anymore. This
guy sucks at making jokes, man.
Terrible. He used to be really good at
it.
He'd like really funny moments, right?
Funny [__] would happen on the stream.
Okay? And then, well, he only has an
audience because he brainwashes the
cult. We did that. Well, he's not a good
debater or smart. He just uses tactics
on people.
Oh, this is This is one. He's not a bad
debater.
But he will just yell over people when
he doesn't have the facts on his side.
He just used to just He just used to
debate the facts. He'd basically say,
what are the things that you prove the
most? And then he would drive people
towards having to engage with like the
facts that he found to prove his
opinion. That's what he was really good
at, right? In my opinion.
Um and then he would get anytime it
would got close or that he was really
out of his depth, he would just get he
essentially kind of asked for turf the
reaction to the debate. It's my opinion.
>> [clears throat]
>> I don't have to like take away the fact
that he was able to build an audience,
man. Yeah, I don't know social export.
It's it's very
Like I
I feel like there's no way he could that
cloudy. Like that like I could not
remember it that badly. Anyway,
every part of my life and success has to
be explained by some insane cope that
just get gets amplified a million times
over.
Okay, I dude,
who's even doing this? Where where is
this self-victimization coming from?
Okay, it unfolded fast because there's a
huge community of people who are trying
to spin them up 1 million percent.
With Connor?
Dude, well, I will say
every time every time well, not every
time cuz it would have been a lot every
time. But my DMs with Connor are
basically like whenever Destiny does
something insanely like antisocial that
would get most influencers canceled to
me, I just shoot it over to Connor. I
don't even like I don't go to a bunch of
people and talk about it. I do shoot it
over to Connor though. Like look at what
this guy just did. Look at this psycho.
Look at this psycho. Look at this
psycho.
Look at this psycho. Look at the And by
the way, Connor would either say that I
don't really care about this, I don't
know what that is, or he he basically
like shot all of them down.
Look at him coming to my chat saying
insane
Look at him trying to like say he thinks
my dad died on Twitter and how funny
that is. Like I By the way, none of it
none of Destiny's affects me, right? It
it just doesn't. It's just like par for
the course, really not a problem. But
it's I just sent it to Connor cuz I'm
like, "Look, he's crashing out. Your
buddy's crashing out. Your buddy's
losing it."
So, for Connor alone I would say, you
know, I did I did actually send stuff to
him cuz I was just like, "Oh, I think
you actually care." I thought I thought
there was a human being somewhere in
there. Anyway, we keep going.
Every part of my life such success to be
explained away by some insane cope. He
did that one. So, steelman the other
side, Hutch, please.
Okay, I'll go. My KF reeks of this type
of theorizing about my life. It is so
funny such insane to see the depths they
have to go to to justify or explain my
existence.
Uh yeah, your KF friend probably thinks
this.
They don't like you.
Lauren has zero reason to have her [__]
leaked out on the internet.
Well, why were you sharing it around to
so many people then? Why'd did DM all of
the Lauren Southern to so many people?
Well, What was going on there? You What
are you doing, man? What are you doing?
What are you doing? What are you doing?
It's actually insane. He keeps doing it.
Lauren and me mutually agreed to split 2
months ago because our lifestyles were
way, way, way too different. She is a
bit more in her, I want to do more
serious, let's settle down media kind of
stuff, and I am still very much in the I
am fighting FOR MY LIFE EVERY DAY. I
LOVE THE BATTLE. LET'S GO, MY BROTHERS,
among other things. Yeah, you're having
a great time. You're having a great
time, man. I can tell.
I can tell he's having a fantastic time.
There is no bad blood or bad feelings or
anything. Connor is dragging all of this
out publicly for literally no reason.
What the
What?
LOL.
What? Can't take criticism. Oh my god.
This is THE MOST HEY, FYI, FYI, FYI,
FYI, FYI.
In case you're listening to this as a
human being, the most insane abuse you
can ever get as a person is someone
treating you like
Well, constantly saying, "I'M ONLY DOING
this because I love you."
Okay. Um
How many times has Connor talked to you
in private about stuff like this or just
mentioned it to you?
And like now it has to be public if he
feels like
I I'm just saying.
Brandon, I feel almost every online
relationship to be on a timer, to be
honest. It's just the way things go.
Okay, what offline relationship for
Destiny is also not on a timer? Which
What relationships for Destiny aren't on
a timer? Like honestly, honest to god.
Which ones? Oh, this is today. Yeah,
this is today while the Hutch stream is
going on.
It's the way things go. Although, I feel
like I'm getting such a clear picture of
things over the past year or more after
seeing how that circle place operates.
Try not to fall too deep into the schizo
thing, but I feel like places have been
operating like this for so long in ways
that I just haven't fully appreciated.
Like realistically, what this is is
there's like communities that are
operating somewhat like DGG chat.
Like that's honest to god what's
happening that he's so upset about. That
there's another community spinning up
that operates just a little bit like DGG
chat.
And he's one of the people that doesn't
like, but there are a lot of people that
it like doesn't not huge fans of.
You know what I mean? Like that's what
he's upset about. It's It what happened
What did they What did they talked
about? These guys search logs,
DGG chat behavior. These guys compile
like like facts or patterns of patterns
of facts that
show how harmful a person could be.
Well, what else did Willy Mac learn this
from if not the output of DGG chat being
recorded on the DGG subreddit? What else
did he make his videos based on? You
know what I mean?
That's what this is all been. It just
slowly moves in the same direction as
DGG chat. It's
And and anything like this existing
somewhere else on the internet is like
just abuse to him. It's abuse, it's
crazy. Anyway,
guy types like he's writing for a gay
anime show. He does a lot of anime
villain monologuing. Yes, he does.
Though I feel like I'm getting such a
clear picture of things over the past
year or more after seeing how that Snark
the place operates. Trying not to fall
too deep into the schizo thing, but I
feel like places have been operating
like this for so long in ways that I
just really haven't fully appreciated.
Remember Vaush came from one of those
communities a long time ago.
Reddit says, dude.
There's no way There's no way that this
guy's talking about like snarker
communities when he's been operating the
biggest snarker community on the
internet for like a decade. How in the
world does he not understand that the
Name a behavior
that any of the communities you're mad
at engage in that your community does
not engage in.
That's all you got to do, man. And they
engage in similarish behavior. Not
saying Vaush is one of these people. I
think me and him are similar in
demeanor. I think he would get bored
being at spaces like this to be honest.
Okay, holy projection.
Holy projection. I didn't invite her to
that event. I didn't pay for her ticket.
WE DIDN'T FLY TOGETHER. WE WEREN'T IN
the same hotel.
She was in the audience. It's not like I
could tell her she's not allowed to come
to the state slash event. Holy
Uh yeah, you could.
Dude, didn't you let her stay at your
place for like a month after that event?
Didn't she fly back to like Miami and
stay in your home for like a month after
that?
What do you mean you can't ask her not
to show up at the event?
Yes, you can.
Hey, you spit on people and then call
them on the internet. You can't be at my
political event. That would be horrible.
Look, it just happened. Look how easy
that was.
I've never even seen her naked.
IRL.
We did not touch. We did not touch or do
anything.
I did not touch that woman. I DID NOT
TOUCH
that insane woman.
I did not. I did not. I did not.
Okay, bro. Okay, man.
WHAT WAS THE DATE, ACTUALLY, FOR THAT
EVENT? TELL ME THE DATE FOR the event.
What was the date with Dyrus in the bad
chat? The reason we said no was because
Connor was the one who leaked it the
first time.
He was the first one to leak or confirm
it last time.
Well, technically no, somebody else
confirmed it last time. And I believe
Melina leaked it before Connor did.
Did Melina not leak it like all over the
place before Connor did?
Mr. Girl knew about it. I could have
sworn that Melina was the one who was
like leaking, unless you mean publicly
Connor like acknowledging it once. I
think Connor just [__] up, though.
Connor giving his final thoughts. Let's
catch up on the logs and then we'll go
back to that, okay?
Our travel plans. We're not even the
same. We're not even the same. Hello
mayo. We did not stay together or fly
back together or anything. She didn't
even know where I was staying that day.
He didn't even know what day I was
leaving.
Let me leak more and more info about my
personal LIFE TO SATISFY EVERYONE ON THE
INTERNET. YES.
Who wants to see my
Just kidding. There are 30 videos of me
out there already. Haha.
Come on, man. Come on. Come on.
Come on.
It's rough. It's very rough, man.
No, we fun-loving regular guy. No, we
didn't. I left without her. She wasn't
aware I was even leaving that day.
DONALD TRUMP LITERALLY INVITED THIS
mistress to a VACATION WITH HIS WIFE.
DUDE,
there's no He's It's so insane. How do
you go to that? And you go to Donald
Trump literally invited his mistress to
a vacation with his wife.
LIKE OKAY. DONALD TRUMP IS THE FIRST
PRESIDENT TO GET CONVICTED OF 34
FELONIES related to him lying ABOUT
PAYING OFF A LAWYER for a porn star.
He's the president of the United States.
[__] days thing is a huge talking
point of the farms. King, I never even
said that. Ever LMFAO. FBI Wait, hold
on. You didn't say that.
You didn't say that, but I do believe
that's like indicated by the logs. I I'm
pretty sure he's basically acknowledged
this.
I never said that. Ever. FBI literally
told me exactly who's making these
threats. LMFAO.
I've never said this in my life.
Um you've said it was my fault you got
calls from the FBI. You've said that
multiple times.
You've literally said this on your
stream. Why are you presenting
otherwise?
This is a super long messy story, BUT
IT'S KIND OF for me to bring it up
because for me to give my side of
anything casts everyone in different
light. These two people are not public
people at all, but I'm sure their
friends are and people they know are
watching. So for me to say anything at
all for about this particular situation
will take all of their personal business
up and throw it into the public light.
So sending his wife's to somebody he
doesn't know from a hole in the ground
totally fine. Him discussing the age
play dynamics that he engaged in with
this person totally insane. He would
never ever do that. That That behavior
is like the shock behavior for me for he
did something [__] up here.
He doesn't think about other people's
boundaries or protecting their privacy
or protecting their safety until he can
weaponize it to defend himself.
This is this there's something going on
here. He does it so often, right?
Like the Rose thing is the was the
perfect example was the quintessential
example of this.
Right? He was trying to dox Rose to get
her in the case. Then when she was
deposed it came out that she was a
minor. Well, sorry, she then people
found out she was minor. Then it came
out that she didn't even have access to
those accounts since she was trafficked,
right? Like technically it's some kind
of trafficking to sell those pictures
like what she's in that relationship.
But you don't even learn that she wasn't
selling them herself or she didn't have
access to the accounts until the
deposition.
So he helped to dox her, then she was
found and deposed and somehow he
moralized the idea of deposing her.
Well, also purportedly wanting to dox
her to depose her for the case because
she had important information for the
case.
The judge himself literally said we
should probably get this person in here.
They didn't know that she wasn't sending
the messages until she was deposed.
So there's just no rational way to say
that it was up to reach out.
When did he message her on Facebook?
After she was doxed as well, yes,
directly. Kind of weird, kind of a
weirdo move to be honest with you.
Very odd.
So again, just the idea of like, oh I I
should never ever do this. It would be
really wrong of me to do that. He
doesn't care about other people's
privacy until
he needs to weaponize it to protect
himself. Very clear every time. This is
this is the exact behavior. But would
anyone ever subject someone to that?
Both of the parts of that couple WERE
LITERALLY BEGGING CONNOR TO stop leaking
and publicizing anything.
All right, we keep going.
If I get murdered or killed or whatever,
please send all my audience and
everything to Hutch. Oh my god, I just
understood all the
I cannot believe how
I am. I just realized dude presents all
of these crazy stupid backstories so
that
if
said he has a good reason never to be
doxed. He does this to shield his
identity. He's so full of
>> [laughter]
>> Mate, how the
[__] I? Did everyone else get this tip
but not me?
>> [laughter]
>> I paired up pedals with Dubie. Who the
[__] is this hanging out with? I'm
taking today off to catch up on
everything I keep start starting late
because I am so buried by so many DMs
and emails related to this I need to
catch up.
He's
He's having a plotting day. Okay. He's
having a plotting day. Very interesting.
Very cool.
Very sick.
Ooh, we have a Connor update. We have a
Connor update. He has been blocked on
Twitter.
It may be over. It may actually be over,
guys.
Connor's been blocked apparently.
Hold on.
I
He's been blocked.
There's a post.
I'm making large changes to my life
going forward. THERE'S NO WAY.
2027 IS THE YEAR THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET
IT ALL RIGHT, GUYS. We're cutting all
the toxic people out of our lives. We're
leaving all the toxic people in 2026.
Say
Say the line, Bart. SAY THE LINE, BART.
>> [laughter]
>> WE'RE LEAVING ALL THESE TOXIC PEOPLE IN
2026, GUYS. And they're all staying back
here.
Uh it's so it's crazy. I'm going to be
creating a watch council. It will
appoint six people, two of my own vote
choosing, two voted for on by chat, and
two voted on by my closest group of
friends. Before I engage with any
individual on a or friendship level, I
will have the council vote upon this
engagement, and it will require at least
4/6 of them to approve it. What is this
like? This is like Cosby saying that
you know, making up a tweet about how
Okay, I guess every single person who
accepts a drink in my house from now on
is just going to have to like have that
drink drug tested. I guess that's that's
reasonable, guys. I guess. I guess
Like, okay. I You're You're being silly
right now. Come on, man. Come on, man.
Be serious
for 2 seconds.
Now, Wick is particularly like
rodent-like. Okay, he's particularly
rat-like when it comes to this
I think we should probably pull the
Reddit post as well. I can't remember if
this before after the hot conversation,
but
on
Anna versus Destiny part two.
This was incredibly sad.
He's forgotten how to be human.
You see someone you consider a friend
being harassed, attacked, literally they
are trying to destroy his life.
They're coming at him,
his child, anyone who works with him,
anyone who's simply insufficiently
anti-Destiny.
He's losing his friends, losing support,
etc.
He's drowning. Dude.
He's the victim. He's the biggest victim
here. He's the biggest victim, guys.
It's
it's crazy. Now,
I don't know like
I think I've linked a grand total of
like maybe three of Nathan's tweets
anywhere that could be trackable on the
internet. Like to laugh at it's mostly
him like saying something funny like on
his dad. I've never covered on stream.
I've explicitly banned him from my
community and banned discussion of him
in my community. So like basically, I've
I feel like I've no responsibility in
terms of going after his child. Nobody
could ever make that argument about me,
okay?
Like in terms of any of the commentary
being made about Nathan or anything
going on there,
so it's just not real. Anyone who's
simply insufficiently anti-Destiny. This
is not not true, right? The issue is
Wick lies. If Wick wouldn't lie in terms
of how he wants to coordinate with
Destiny or cooperate with Destiny, if he
wouldn't lie and change his community
rules and piss everybody off, like this
is his problem. It's a Wick problem.
It's not a anti-Destiny problem. It's
not a Stalker problem. It's just a Wick
problem. Anyway, so Wick is, you know,
self-victimizing, making Destiny the
biggest victim.
Okay, let's take a look.
Confession.
I don't know what to do here
or if I should do anything.
Who am I after all?
I have a professional relationship with
both of these gentlemen.
I am not their friend, strictly
speaking.
We are friendly, but there is a
difference.
Should I have even stepped in?
Frankly, no. This all should have been
done in private. But they were doing it
in public, and I happened to see it. All
of this All of this madness.
It made me consider how I engage. Maybe
keeping professional distance has been a
mistake.
They seem to need friends right now.
Hell, I know I do.
I'll talk more about this on Monday, but
it's been incredibly disheartening to
see how many people consider everything
happening to me
to be just content.
I get this is all super soy,
but I am soy. I embrace it,
I suppose.
All this to say,
and I know this is a bit of stream of
consciousness rant,
but streaming makes us forget how to be
human a bit.
My appeal to you, dear viewer,
remember, we're not just streamers.
We are human beings.
Give us all some grace.
Okay. All right. That was a little
nauseating to do for that long.
That was [__] up.
Let me make sure I've got the timestamp
for the Wick call-in. Here we go. Here
we go. Hey, what's up, man?
I was watching you cover this little
bit. Uh I was curious you'd take it. Uh
it's pretty based, okay? Your kind of
intuition here kind of follows mine, but
um I think it I I tried to to tell
Connor this
All of the low IQ terrible entertainers
are following the same intuition, which
is not shocking.
>> um over the last 2 days, but I don't
think he was listening to me.
Uh but there's like context to all this
that I think
really
should be known.
>> Oh?
What is the context?
>> clear, I don't have like uh
all the information. I don't have access
to the logs or anything like these
things, but I do know information,
right? That does put a lot of this into
context, just based on my experiences
previously and what's happening to me
right now.
Uh that uh
it might help not only you, but your
audience to kind of understand what's
going on. All right. This was
a successful op.
These people
turned
Conner into a weapon
and watched him immolate himself live on
air.
Um in order to further isolate
>> you suspect that or do you know that for
sure? I suspect it.
>> Okay.
>> I suspect it because I'll tell you why.
Yeah. So, the other day
uh
I got wind that Destiny was going to
change his rules.
That he was going to start banning
anyone who had Duby in their space.
Okay?
And this is something that people
started DMing me, right? And I saw
people start talking about it. You know,
the same names I usually see, right?
Saying, "Ooh,
you stood up for Destiny and he's going
to kick you out. Ooh, look, Destiny's
going to blacklist you. Haha, after all
you did." Right? And kind of putting
these seeds out there, right? Kind of
creating this impression that this was
going to happen.
Um I reached out to Destiny.
We had a
uh
short, productive talk live on air,
right? I said, "Hey,
His rules. Rules for what, Wick? Rules
for his slaves? Yeah, it's like, "I'm
going to do my boundaries that are
actually boundaries for how you run your
professional like your you the your
little profession, your job. My
boundaries as a friend are here's how
you do your job.
Here's how you write code or some [__]
right? Dude, what?
How can that be a part of your
friendship boundaries? That seems crazy.
I um I'm not comfortable banning someone
from my community that hasn't broke the
rules, uh but I understand that you have
legitimate concerns. What can we do?
Um and we got to compromise. I didn't
have to ban anyone from my server. I
said, "Okay, well, I'll just let you if
you're concerned that my space is being
used as like a
snarker pep rally, uh you can come into
my space anytime, right? And see what's
going on, and I'll give you full access
to the VCs and all that, and you can go
in and check all you want." Um that way
I didn't have to ban anyone.
And he can see if there is snarker pep
rallies going on in my server or not. I
thought it was a
decent compromise, not perfect, but it
allowed me to kind of
By the way, I believe this like really
pissed people off in the wig cord cuz
they like having the no recording of VCs
rule. And they basically gave like
Destiny an all-access pass to go and
record the VCs. And I think they also
found out that people in Destiny's
communities had been recording those VCs
for a long time, and the response to
them recording those VCs and then
forcing Wick via an ultimatum to make a
decision there was Wick was like, "Okay,
I capitulate entirely on the recording."
You know what I mean?
Very goofy, very sad.
>> space and keep my rules without
um
entirely compromising
um everything I wanted to do.
So, I know what was happening to me at
that time, and how people were reacted
to me at that time. I suspect they were
also doing this to Connor. I suspect
they were also in his ear saying, "Cool.
Mhm. After all you've done, Destiny's
going to blacklist you.
Destiny's going to cut you off, man.
He's threatening you. Look, you got to
stand up to him. You got to have a
spine. You got to have a backbone. He's
going to burn you, man. You got You got
to take control."
And uh well, it created uh the situation
that we find ourselves in today.
Um that's why
Uh I didn't say that to Connor. I
actually Yeah, I don't know who would
have been saying that to Connor. Cuz
like I heard him say that a couple
times.
Right? That Oh, well, I'm not going to
let you tell me what to do.
I don't think I ever really made that
point to Connor. I don't Like listen,
you
You want to have like or you want to
basically
capitulate to this guy's neuroses,
that's fine. Especially like a temporary
situation.
I don't understand why Like why people
would even Sorry, I don't understand how
Wick thinks like snarkers, quote
unquote, would be mad about that. For
Wick, I think it was mostly his
community that was pissed about that.
Right? I'm guessing for Connor, it might
be people who are pissed in his
community, too. I'm not sure.
Threatening you. Look, you got to stand
up to him. You got to have a spine. You
got to have a backbone. He's going to
burn you, man. You got You got to take
control.
And oh, well, it created uh the
situation that we find ourselves in
today. Um, that's why I suspect what I
did. And I I'm I'm pretty confident with
my analysis here. What do you think from
outside perspective? There's There's
things that I know that I can't that I
can't like say.
But uh let's
Why Why would there be Dude, like the
very idea that you're going to go and
just get everybody to like stay on board
with you never releasing things, but
you're going to make all kinds of
allegations. It's so
gay, man. It's so unfathomably
gay.
Dude, it's so crazy. I don't think Wick
understands what he's saying here. He's
just effectively said that having a
spine is dumb. Well, I mean
I'll be honest, having a spine can be
dumb.
Like I don't know if you watched the
segment yesterday on Chud Sourcing
Support, but I basically argued that for
Chud, having a spine would be dumb.
Like actually, you shouldn't have a
spine in this situation.
I totally get it. You got a kids, you
got a mortgage. Yes, you I get it.
All I'm asking is for you not to be an
anchor. That's all. Don't be an anchor
on the people who do want to do that,
who do want to stand with a spine in
this situation. You know what I mean?
That's all.
Sometimes if Wick wants to say that, if
Wick is like I can't if he's going to
capitulate and say I can't make a go of
this in any way unless I'm subservient
to Destiny, so I had to maintain that
bridge. He wants to be honest about
that, that's fine.
To me,
but you should be honest about it. It
shouldn't be like oh, you're standing on
principle and you're doing this to like
make sure you run the space you the way
you want. You were running the space the
way you wanted.
You're not anymore. Now you're running
it the way somebody else wanted. And
you're leaving out all the stuff that's
important there, which is you don't
think you could make a go of it unless
you did that. Say I'm Am I Am I Am I Am
I close?
I would say I'm I'm vibing with what
you're saying. I'm following what you're
saying. Yeah.
It It does appear just like publicly
just based on like public information
that uh
their whole thing is is like
infiltrating other spaces and then using
those spaces as like a proxy
fight with Destiny. That That appears to
be happening like just out in the open.
And um yeah, the whole thing is just
like very dark I got banned for from J's
Doc server for potential doxxing lol.
I'm pretty sure that person has posted
doc stuff as well, but whatever. Keep
going.
>> like that I find it all very disturbing.
It's all very dark and disturbing like
that level of involvement and emotional
investment and uh
obsession and
Let's be clear, this is like the the
least of it. Um
I mean, I I got doxxed, right? And not
only me. And I And I talked to him,
right? Just
Does Wick understand that his doxxing is
like absolutely like not connected to
the Snarker server?
Like does he understand that? That his
name would have been out publicly due to
the PB filings and Old Man Laundry's
article before that? And that that
information being posted in that server
was after he was originally doxxed, at
least the name?
Like does Wick really have no concept of
this whatsoever?
Like I
I don't know.
That That just feels bizarre to me that
Destiny knows that his friends like have
like because of how he's run his career
basically
there's a KF threat. Well, maybe I won't
even say that. There is a KF threat.
Like cuz obviously KF could have a
problem with you even if you weren't
like some crazy problematic person. So,
without even casting judgment on that
part, although I do have that judgment,
I'll say that he has a KF threat where
and he's had it for a long time since
maybe '23, '22 where they've been
doxxing people around him, right? '23 at
least I think.
And
he doesn't inform his friends about
this? He doesn't keep an eye on it or
have somebody to keep an eye on it so he
could inform his friends if like their
information's posted? Does he have no
concern about that whatsoever?
Like that just seems totally to me that
you don't let these people know at all
this [__] that's going on. Like Wick
Wick should know the PV filings were how
his information got out and then
multiple people have published that
information before the Starker Discord
ever had that information in there.
Now, that doesn't mean it's not doxxing
if somebody was doing that to harass,
right? If somebody was doing that hoping
someone would go and harass Wick with
it. It doesn't mean it wasn't something.
Person still got banned.
But obviously
Wick thinks that like something unique
happened there.
I'm telling you Wick, this is not the
first time your your stuff has been on
like some public forum.
I'm sorry to inform you of that. It's
just not. Like he's now Now he's talking
about it openly so I don't feel bad
saying it. But this was not the first
time this happened. Nobody wants to
point it out because obviously it is
like a disservice to you in some way if
you haven't acknowledged this [__] and
talked about it openly.
Obviously.
Anyway, we keep going.
>> make sure that it was they were okay
with with me sharing. I I talked to one
last night. Um
Uh Tally got doxxed because of her
relationship with me and Destiny.
Um
Stardust got doxxed. We're not talking
just like
Destiny and them talking Destiny.
They're talking
targeting people associated with
Destiny, even very, very loosely. It is
been going on for months.
For months.
>> Probably probably probably over a year.
Uh at this point.
>> have no idea. Um
but people like Queenman,
people like uh J Stock and all these
people are encouraging and facilitating
this behavior. And it's not doxing
Evidence. Evidence. Evidence. Evidence.
Evidence. Evidence. Evidence.
You don't get to make this allegation
and then [__] off and never say anything
about the evidence. You don't get to do
that. Evidence. I it's so crazy, man. I
don't like what do you even say to like
this?
Oh yeah, there's there's like total
skitzos doxing a bunch of people and
Wick is just going to go put a target on
other people's back. Okay, well
whatever.
>> all of it. It's constant harassment. Um
I've I've clips of Queenman
uh from maybe a year Wick can't pretend
not to know Queen because Wick had Queen
in blacklisted, right? So Wick can't
pretend not to know him.
>> here maybe two years ago. I'm not not
sure off the top of my head. Basically
uh painting me as a
uh someone who
assaults women. Yeah, I saw that.
>> Because he found a picture of me, right?
With
uh at at TwitchCon with my arm around a
woman or something, right?
Um
and painting me as all these things.
Just the most slanderous, libelous
And this is what they do. And they say
it's a joke, but this is a constant
thing. This is not a joke. They are not
This is a motte and bailey they do.
They'll pretend it's a joke if they get
caught, but they'll treat it seriously
if they can. Mhm. And it is insane.
These people are insane. And I tried to
tell Counter-Points this. I tried to
tell Connor this. I tried to be like,
"Bro, like I I don't have a smoking gun
for you, but I don't need a smoking gun
for you to know that these people are
all connected to know to know that all
these people are constantly just going
through all your data, all your posts,
everything. Like right now, they're You
don't need I mean, you would need Okay,
your post. We go through your public
content. That is obviously true. That we
do watch your public content.
What is the evidence that we go through
like all of your data or something like
this? Like I'm so sorry, Wick, that you
were doxxed by the PB filings. I've read
that that article on stream once Ludwig
like updated it and removed the doxx
from the main article. I've watched it
on stream.
They're they're watching right now,
right? In the stream, they had tons of
people spamming Do you like Zepeto? But
Queen Mary Wick a creep a few years ago.
Uh Queen Mary pushed it probably like
right up to the line.
He explained to me what he did last
night
in that conversation last night, dude.
He um
I think he said that Wick touched the
thigh of Madam No, Madam Genevieve and
Ginger Amarath.
He said he touched them like
non-consensually. Cuz they asked Ginger,
"Did Wick ask for consent before
touching your thigh?" And she said, "No,
he didn't." But not saying that he was
like a something like that. So, Queen
Mary says, "Well, Wick touched her
non-consensually."
And it sounds a certain way. It's like
strictly correct, but it sounds a
certain way. Obviously, he's doing
something there cuz he finds it funny.
He's a little psycho, man. He's a little
psycho.
>> Hi to snarkers. How you doing? And
they're workshopping what to do, what to
say, how to spin it, all these things.
And they're going into communities and
they're going into streamers' heads and
they're getting into your head and it's
insane. So, for Counter-Points to not
even allow us to have that discussion.
And instead, he decided to litigate
Destiny's life. Who the [__] cares about
Destiny's life?
The trial of Steven Destiny Bonnell and
his
sins. Yeah.
He does not He's very very He was very
very um emotionally [clears throat]
invested in it and and uh
it was it was a little
uh Well, he because they primed him.
They primed the pump. They've been feed
like they've been spitting in his ear uh
playing to his suspicions. They've been
finding weaknesses and it's a strat and
they won last night. Like
Counter-Points, this did not have to
happen how it happened.
Um what do you mean won last night? When
was the last time we didn't win?
But
I I get When was the last time we didn't
win, man?
I but I tried to stop it. I tried to
calm him down, but I failed. I just
straight up I failed. Um Well, he
>> got he got activated and once he got
activated, I mean Connor, once he got
activated, there's no
You can't really It's hard to talk
people down when they're in that kind of
a place.
I know. It should not have happened
publicly. Like look,
that if if they have friendship troubles
like that, um that should have been a
private conversation.
I have no idea why
Counter-Points decided to litigate that
um on a stream. I have no idea.
But that If I have a problem with
someone as a friend, um
Yeah, I I don't I don't That's not
content. It's something else and uh
Dude, it's it's so crazy that this is
the way they see it.
Like I could easily talk to Wick about
this, right?
I could easily talk to Wick about this.
I don't know why Wick keeps saying that
this is a problem. This is like a huge
issue. Connor just ambushed him.
Connor was waiting for Destiny. Destiny
wanted that conversation.
And clearly Destiny was saying this
isn't a problem. It's a thing from way
long ago. It's been It's crazy. It's
like so long ago. You're only litigating
things for a year or two ago. Two years
ago. And Connor goes, "Dude, I had a
problem with you like a week ago over
this."
Like this problem is now.
So Destiny's trying to lie and say,
"Well, all the problems that people have
a thing with, they happened way so they
happened so long ago that you shouldn't
even litigate them anymore." And Connor
goes, "Hey, you're just lying."
You're just lying. Here's something I
was talking to you about very recently.
I don't know, man. I'm
I'll just say this all all is escalating
and I don't know how to put the
toothpaste back in the tube.
I don't know I don't know what to do.
Yeah, I don't know either. It's crazy.
It seems like these guys have have have
have
I mean like the snarkers have
like it's it's now they've now
assimilated all of this conflict as a
like a like a big part of their
personalities.
Like a big part of their identities. And
for as long as that remains true, then
I don't think they're going to stop.
They're going to
keep being obsessed and
uh
with people that have even like five
degrees of separation
from
uh Destiny or or even people like you or
Lonerbox or whatever.
You don't have five degrees of
separation, you lying
You went on a You had a fight with Pisco
and you went on Destiny's stream for a
post like a post-debate debrief.
Hey, how did I do? Hey, how did I do,
man?
How did I do?
You're like an embarrassing loser.
And I tried I gave this guy the benefit
of the doubt. That's the up thing. I
gave him the benefit of the doubt and I
said, "You know, we're not going to have
to We don't have to like
call him a DGG or whatever. Like I get
he feels disconnected from that
community." And I I his position was
fine.
But then he totally lied and he went
back on that position. He totally
capitulated. He said I would need to see
some form of like apology. I would need
to see some form of making things right.
I need to see some acknowledgement.
And him trying to become a better
person. That has not happened. Not even
a little bit. And Hutch ended up going
and interacting with him and collabing
with him again. I'm going to hold you
that principle now.
When you say that you need to see some
acknowledgement, some apology, an effort
to become better.
None of those things have happened. You
are a liar.
Anyway, and it's just transparently for
money and clout. Come on, man.
>> Whatever. Like as long as
you know, yeah.
Yeah, it's it's it's something where
it's it's a a very effective thing to
continually put out the
to flood the zone with [__] and
basically say something loud enough,
often enough, retweet it, get your
friends to retweet it, get your buddies
to like it and say variations of that,
have people react to the streams where
it happens and then react to those
reacts and all these things to create
this like public perception of what's
happening that is not based in truth at
all. And there's again evidence
that I haven't seen all of to be clear,
but I've I've seen enough that I'm I'm
very confident that this is a
coordinated, purposeful strategy that
they're engaging in and it's cellular.
Meaning that some of them are directly
engaged and some of them are indirectly
engaged so that they have plausible
deniability.
And I don't know how to I don't know how
to deal with it or fix it, but people
have to
Wow.
When
when Substance puts a a clip in the chat
and just says juice it, when Substance
puts like a clip in and just says juice
the tweets, guys. That's like a
complicated, complex scheme that
nobody's ever thought of before. Except
like everybody on the internet ever.
>> it's happening. And to be clear, they've
This is they've done it to me. Like
people in DGG who or who have DGG tags
will come to me and say, "Well, Destiny
actually really hates you. Destiny
actually thinks you're He's making fun
of you all the time." And they're Okay.
I need proof of that. I need proof of
that. I need proof of that now. Give me
proof of that
trying to drive that wedge, but it I
don't I don't believe that. I don't
believe that. I feel like that's If
that's happened more than once,
like I I can maybe believe some schizos
doing that, but the idea that there's
multiple people doing it, get off, man.
Nobody cares about Wick that much. I'm
sorry, WICK. YOU'RE NOT IMPORTANT.
You're literally not important at all.
>> It's an op, right? It's an op.
Yeah, they
They were They were baiting me for
months.
Yep.
They were And I didn't become aware of
it until You're You're confusing baiting
you with making fun of you for being a
They're different. They're different
things.
>> little mole hit me up. And then it when
I saw the level of bait, I felt so
stupid.
These guys baited me so many times, bro.
So many times. And it was so
coordinated. It was so organized. It's
embarrassing. And so now it made me
reevaluate stuff. And so now I'm like
just suspicious and so So. Yeah.
>> My mission now is to just make people
aware
and to make as many people aware as
possible. And like I said, I I don't
have any smoking guns for you. I don't
have all the pieces of the puzzle. But
you know how when you build a puzzle,
there's a point where even if you don't
have all the pieces together, you know
what you know it's a you know what it's
a picture of. It's a picture of a clown
or a zoo or whatever.
>> Well, so much of it so much of it
happened just right in the open. Like
so, you know.
I I think yeah, I don't think you need
access to the logs to see
what was going on there. I mean love I
love that Hutch reacted to Hutch my
contact. I love that. I love that for
him. I'll see you later, man. Thanks for
coming on. I appreciate it. Of course.
Bye. Bye-bye.
Yeah, I've no idea. So, Wick comes on
and implies that we're doxers. There is
a Discord we're in where a picture of
Wick with like a like his name was in
it.
With the message was deleted very
quickly. Apparently, the artifact from
the Twitter bot stayed there for a
while.
Other than that, it's like, dude, it's
nothing. They've got nothing.
It's like that [__] That [__] that
happened. I wish that hadn't happened to
Wick.
But, it doesn't mean I'm to blame for
stuff that was already out there, man.
I'm sorry.